you always hear that um cliche about
good looking guys that that they're
terrible in bed you hear it you hear it
I don't really know if that's true that
I don't think that's been my experience
really not somebody's been around block
that much but regardless good looking
guys they always say they don't have to
work at anything because girls want to
be with them because they're good
looking so they get the girl into bed
and they never had to figure out how to
work the Machinery so they don't know
how and they're just like oh what's
going on here and they just kind of like
get through it
um as opposed to guys that maybe didn't
have it so easy and weren't as good
looking but they had to you know figure
out maybe they became really funny and
they became really charming and they
were like I'm gonna figure out a woman's
body because I'm gonna make her really
happy to you know be with me and they
just worked a little harder so if you're
good looking don't see it as a past just
saying there's a lot more to the package
that is interesting than just what you
look like that's going to be like boring
after like five seconds